you talked about one interesting
difference also between the sort of uh
the Gom the
Gil uh front end and the uh base B jazza
back end is the communication Styles
also that you were exploring different
ways of U communicating that can be more
viral yeah in the way that we
communicate in the 21st century also the
movement that you mentioned that you
started it's not just a meme account but
there's also a a name to it called
effect of accelerationism
e a play a
resistance to the effective altruism
movement also an interesting one that
I'd love to talk to you about the
tensions there okay and so then there
was a merger a get get merge on the
personalities uh recently without your
consent like you said uh some
journalists figured out that
you're one and the same maybe you could
talk about that experience first of all
like what what's the story of of uh the
merger of the two
right so I wrote the manifesto uh with
my co-founder of eak an account named
Bas Lord still Anonymous luckily um and
hopefully forever so it's based buff
jzos and and based like basian Lord like
beian Bean Lord B Be Lord okay and so we
should say from now on we when you say
eak you mean e
slac which stands for Effective
accelerationism that's right and you're
referring to a Manifesto written on uh I
guess substack yeah are you also Bas
Lord no okay it's a different person
yeah okay well there you go um would it
be funny if I'm B Lord that'd be
amazing so originally wrote the
manifesto around the same time as I
founded uh this company and I worked at
Google X or just X now or alphabet X now
that there's another X um and there you
know the Baseline is sort of secrecy
right uh you you you can't talk about
what you work on even with other
googlers uh or externally and so that
was kind of deeply ingrained in my way
to do things especially in in deep Tech
that you know has
geopolitical impact right um and so I
was being secretive about what I was
working on there's no correlation
between my company and my main identity
publicly and then not only did they
correlate that they also correlated my
main identity and this
account so I think the fact that they
had docked the whole guom complex um and
they were the journalists you know
reached out to actually my investors uh
which is pretty scary uh you know when
you're a startup entrepreneur you don't
really have bosses except for your
investors right um and U my investors
ping me like hey this this is going to
come out they've they've figured out
everything what are what are you going
to do right um and so I think at first
they had a first reporter on the
Thursday and didn't have all the pieces
together but then they looked at their
notes across the organization and they
sensor fused their notes and now they
had way too much uh and that's when I
got worried cuz they said it was of
public
interest and in general like how you
said sensor
fused like it's some giant your old
Network operating in in distributed way
we should also say that the journalist
used I guess at the end of the day
audio- based analysis of voice yeah
comparing voice of what talks you've
given in the past and then uh voice on
um X spaces yep okay so uh and that
that's where the primarily the match was
happened okay continue the match but you
know they they scraped uh you know SEC
filings uh they looked at my private
Facebook account uh so on so they they
did they did some digging originally I
thought that doxing was illegal right um
but there's this weird threshold when it
becomes of public interest to know
someone's identity and those were the
key wordss that sort of like Ring the
Alarm bells for me when they said
because I had just reached 50k followers
allegedly that's of public interest and
so where where do we draw the line when
is it legal to to dock someone the word
docks maybe you can educate me I thought
doxing generally refers to if somebody's
physical location is found out meaning
like where they
live so we're referring to the more
General concept
of revealing private information that
you don't want revealed is what you mean
by doxing I think that you know for the
reasons we listed before uh having an
anonymous account is a really powerful
way to keep the powers that be in check
um you know we were ultimately speaking
truth to power right I think a lot of
Executives and AI companies really cared
what our community thought um about any
move they may take and now that you know
my identity is revealed now they know
where to apply pressure to silence me or
maybe the community and to me that's
that's really unfortunate um because
again it's so important for us to have
freedom of speech which induces freedom
of thought um and and Freedom of
Information propagation right on social
media which thanks to Elon purchasing uh
Twitter now x uh we we have that um and
so to us you know we wanted to call out
certain Maneuvers um being done by the
incumbents in AI as not what it may seem
on the surface right we're calling out
how certain proposals might be useful
for regulatory capture right and how uh
the
to point that out um and just have the
ideas that we put out evaluated for
themselves right that ultimately that's
why I created an an anonymous account
it's to have my ideas valuated for
themselves uncorrelated from my track
record my job or or status from uh
having done things in the past and and
to me starting account from from zero to
a large following uh in a way that
wasn't dependent on my identity Andor
achievements you know that was that was
very fulfilling right uh it's kind of
like New Game Plus in a video game you
restart the video game with your
knowledge of how to beat it maybe some
tools while you restart the video game
from scratch right and um I think to
have a truly efficient Marketplace of
ideas where we can evaluate
ideas however of the beaten path they
are we need the freedom of expression
and I think that anonymity um and
pseudonyms are very crucial to having
that efficient Marketplace of ideas for
us to
find the the Optima of all sorts of ways
to organize ourselves if we can't
discuss things how are we going to
converge on the best way to do things so
it was it was disappointing to hear that
I was getting doxed and I wanted to get
in front of it um because I had a
responsibility for for for my company um
and so I you know we ended up
disclosing uh they were running a
company some of the leadership um and uh
essentially yeah uh I I told the world
that I was uh bef Jos because they they
had me cornered at that point so to you
it's fundamentally unethical like uh so
one is unethical for them to do what
they did but also do you think think not
just your case but in the general case
is it good for society is it bad for
society
to uh remove the cloak of anonymity or
is it Case by case I think it could be
quite bad like I said if anybody who
speaks truth to power and and sort of
starts a a movement or an uprising
against the incumbents against those
that usually control the flow of
information if anybody
that reaches a certain threshold gets um
doxed and thus the traditional apparatus
has ways to apply pressure on them to
suppress their
speech I I think that's you know that's
a speech suppression mechanism an idea
suppression complex as uh Eric Weinstein
would would
say